distressing scenes in copenhagen
fans and players watched on in horror as
denmark star
christian eriksen collapsed in their
euro 2020 match against finland
his teammates formed a human shield
around him as he was given cpr on the
pitch for several minutes before being
taken away on a stretcher
the fixture was suspended with those
left in the stadium fearing the worst
but then more positive news a photograph
emerged showing the midfielder raising
his hand as he was carried off
it was then confirmed by the tournament
organizers that eriksen was stable and
conscious in hospital
denmark's football association said
their players were able to communicate
directly with ericsson
and the decision was taken by both teams
to restart the game
the finns clapping the danes back onto
the field
before going on to win one nil
[Applause]
i'm very affected myself i was involved
in a similar situation as a coach where
we almost lost someone
everyone is now reaching out to their
family trying to facetime them
all of our thoughts and prayers are with
christian and his family
ericsson was clearly on the minds of the
teams playing in the later game in group
e
romelu lukaku scored the opening goal in
belgium's 3-0 win over russia
he's a teammate of eritsen at inter
milan and dedicated the goal to him
shocking scenes but this has happened
before in 2012 fabrice muamba collapsed
on the field while playing for his club
in the fa cup in england
muamba said erickson's collapse brought
him to tears
it's almost like it broke back stuff
that i've
put down in me i've this emotion that
just
deep down there i never want to relieve
it again and then to
watch it from that distance and not
knowing
the expectation was gonna happen
it's scary
ericsson is 29 years old and has never
contracted covert 19
and has no medical conditions that he's
aware of according to inter's team
physician
he has passed every medical exam since
joining from tottenham 18 months ago
erickson remains in hospital and is
undergoing tests
peter stem at al jazeera well sanjay
sharma is a professor of cardiology at
st
george's university of london he also
worked with premier league clubs
including tottenham
where eriksen once played and joins me
now on skype
uh sanjay we've seen this sort of thing
happen before with fabrice muamba who we
heard from there and tragically with
mark vivian foway
what causes these sudden collapses
i'll start i'd like to start by saying
that they are uncommon they affect one
in fifty thousand athletes
but when they do occur they're usually
due to an underlying heart fault usually
a genetic fault that runs in families
or a congenital fault that someone's
born with and these faults may affect
the muscle of the heart
the electrical system of the heart or
even the blood supply of the heart
so you know as you as uh the commentator
just said that
uh people that are high level sports
people
are tested for these types of conditions
because of the impact that a cardiac
arrest has
not just on them and their families but
also on the general population
and christian ericsson certainly was
tested for
several years whilst he was a player at
spurs and then went on to have a normal
medical assessment
at inter milan and what this begs the
question as to what happened
you know was it something that these
cardiac screening programs
were unable to identify such as a subtle
scar in the heart
or a blocked artery or it was it
something that either quiet maybe he'd
had a viral illness
or was slightly below par before he
played i'm sure that these
answers may come to light after the
danish cardiologists have finished all
of their investigations
the medical teams there in copenhagen
reacted incredibly fast last night
how crucial is the time to the survival
of someone who's had an episode like
this
and how important is it to have
equipment like a defibrillator on site
well we must congratulate them i think
the the efforts were fantastic and as a
result of that we've got a
young man who is alive and will will
live for several decades
um it's absolutely crucial to get the
heart started once there's a sudden
cardiac arrest because for every minute
that lapses the chances of survival drop
by between
seven and ten percent so when someone
has a cardiac arrest the important thing
is to start
cpr immediately within two minutes which
was the case
to keep all the other organs perfused
such as the brain clearly if the brain
doesn't get
oxygen for enough time then the
individual could be left with brain
damage in the future
and of course whilst keeping that uh
resuscitation process going if there is
a shockable rhythm such as ventricular
fibrillation which was the case with
fabrice muamba
the important aim is to deliver an
electrical shock within two or three
minutes to try and get that heart
started as quickly as possible and it
seems
that this is what happened in that
christian eriksen's downtime
that is the time between the collapse
and the time that
they got everything going again was
really very short and therefore his
outlook is good
it's actually crucial that these
defibrillators pitch side defibrillators
are available
i can only speak for the english
football association where all
92 clubs affiliated with the english
football association do have
such pitch side care professor sanjay
sharma thank you very much for joining
us and your insight on that
thank you